wanna be happy build a life not just a
business
hey it's evan carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one challenge that is holding
you back
a lack of belief in yourself you watch
these videos because you
know there's something more inside you
too you've got michael jordan level
genius at
something so today let's live your best
believe life and get some
amazing motivation from jeff bezos
enjoy
you cannot invent and pioneer
if you cannot accept failure to
to invent you need to experiment and if
it's if you know
in advance that it's going to work it is
not
an experiment and so that's a very
important thing you you know
it's they are inseparable twins failure
and invention
so you have to be willing to do that and
it's embarrassing to fail
um you know it's always embarrassing to
fail but you have to say no
that's not how this works if i said to
you you have a 10
chance of a with a particular decision a
10
chance of a 100 x return you should take
that bet every time
but you're still going to be wrong 9 out
of 10 times and it's going to feel bad 9
or 10 times
and in in with technology the outcomes
the results can be very long tailed the
it's very the payoff is can be very
asymmetric which is why you should do so
much experimentation
you know everybody knows that if you
swing for the fences you hit more home
runs but you also strike out more
but with baseball that analogy doesn't
go far enough because with baseball
no matter how well you connect with the
ball you can only get four runs
the success is capped at four runs
but in business every once in a while
you step up to the plate
and you hit the ball so hard you get a
thousand runs
and so when that when you have that kind
of asymmetric payoff
and you know one up one at back can get
you a thousand runs
it encourages you to experiment more
it's the right business decision to
experiment more
it's also better for your customers
customers like the
successful experiments we all have
adversity in our lives
you i i would i would i doubt if you
really
you know if you know somebody any friend
or anybody that you talk to
there's no lack of adversity and the
uh and by the way that's good because
it's what teaches us how to get back up
you fall down you get back up
it always happens and uh you know you
get certain um gifts in life and you
want to take advantage of those
um but you i guess my advice on
adversity and uh success
would be to be proud
not of your gifts but of your hard work
and your choices so you know you may be
the kinds of gifts you get you know you
might be really good at math
it might be really easy for you that's a
kind of gift
but practicing that math and taking it
to the next step
that could be very challenging and hard
and take a lot of sweat that's a choice
you can't really be proud of your gifts
because they were given to you
you can be grateful for them and
thankful for them
and but your choices you choose to work
hard
you choose to do hard things those are
choices that you can be proud of i spent
an unusual amount of time
with my grandparents and especially with
my grandfather on the ranch so he had a
ranch in south texas
and i would spend my summers there from
age 4 to 16.
and they when i was four they were
taking me for the summer to kind of give
my parents a break
you know it's sort of because they were
so young
and it was useful i was a handful i'm
sure and
uh and anyway he he he
he created the illusion for me when i
was four years old that i was helping
him
on the ranch which of course could not
have been true
but i believed it and um and then as by
the time i was 16 of course i was
actually helping on the ranch i you know
i could i can fix prolapsed cattle i can
you know we did all of our own
veterinary work some of the cattle even
survived
and uh we fixed windmills and laid you
know water pipelines and built fences
and barns and
fixed that fixed the bulldozer that you
guys talked about
and so one of the things that's so
interesting about that
lifestyle and about my grandfather is he
did everything
himself you know he didn't call a vet if
one of the animals was sick he figured
out
what to do himself and uh so what does
it mean no delegation being resourceful
i think is the you know that you can
always you can't if there's a problem
there's a solution and of course as you
as you
mature and and get into the business
world and anything you do on a team you
very quickly realize that
it's not about just your own
resourcefulness it's about
team resourcefulness also if you want to
have more self-confidence and
self-belief i've designed a special
free training to help you get it where
every day for the next 254 days i will
send you
a link to an unlisted video to your
email
to every day shift your confidence and
self-belief forward
the science says it can take up to 254
days
of consecutive action to make a habit
stick
and i want you to get the habit of
self-confidence and self-belief
the link to join absolutely for free is
in the description
below if everything has to work in two
to three years
then that limits what you can do the
stress primarily comes
from not taking action if you're doing
anything interesting in the world
you're going to have critics the only
way if you absolutely can't tolerate
critics then don't do anything new
or interesting if you're giving great
customer experience
um there's the only way to do that
is with happy people you can't do it
with a set of miserable people
um you know watching the clock all day
so does that include work-life balance
and all those things
yes but i would i use i teach um three
uh leadership classes a year at amazon
i'm a part of it
they're bigger classes but i come in and
teach a session and
i always talk about work-life balance
except i like to use the phrase
work-life harmony
rather than balance because to me
balance
implies a strict trade
whereas i find that when i am
happy at work i come home
more energized i'm a better husband a
better dad
and when i'm happy at home i come in and
better boss and better colleague
and so that that um
it's not you could be out of work and
be have terrible work life balance you
know even though you've got all the time
in the world
right you could just feel like oh my god
you know i'm miserable and you would be
draining energy
and so you have to find that harmony
it's a much better word
and i think for most people it's about
meaning people want to know that they're
doing something
interesting and useful and for us you
know because of the challenges that we
have
chosen for ourselves we get to work
in the future and it's super fun to work
in the future for the right kind of
person
ever since i was five years old that's
when neil armstrong stepped onto the
surface of the moon
i've been kind of passionate about
space rockets rocket engines space
travel
i became a science fiction reader
and i've always known that i wanted to
you know do something having to do with
space and i've spent a lot of time
thinking about it
from really almost my whole life and
that's one of the things you guys will
find
that you have passions and having a
passion is a gift
i think we all have passions and you
don't get to
choose them they pick you but you have
to be alert to them you have to be
looking for them
and when you find your passion it's a
fantastic gift for you because
it gives you direction it gives you
purpose you can have a job
or you can have a career or you can have
a calling and the best thing is to have
a calling and if you find your passion
you'll have that and
all your work won't feel like work to
you it's easy to have ideas
it's very hard to turn an idea into a
successful product
there are a lot of steps in between it
takes persistence
relentlessness so i always tell people
who
are you know who think they want to be
entrepreneurs it's
you need a combination of
stubborn relentlessness and
flexibility and you have to know when to
be which
and basically you need to be stubborn on
your vision
because otherwise it'll be too easy to
give up but you need to be very flexible
on the details
because as you go along pursuing your
vision you'll find that some of your
preconceptions were wrong
and you're going to need to be able to
change those things
so i think taking an idea successfully
all the way to the market and turning it
into a real product that people care
about that really improves people's
lives
is a lot of hard work my job one of my
jobs
as the leader of amazon is to encourage
people
to be bold and people love to focus on
things that aren't yet working
and that's good it's human nature that
kind of divine discontent can be very
helpful
but you really you know it's incredibly
hard to get people to take bold bets
and you need to encourage that and if
you're going to take bold bets
they're going to be experiments and if
they're experiments you don't know ahead
of time
they're going to work experiments are by
their very nature
prone to failure but big successes a few
big successes
compensate for dozens and dozens of
things that didn't work
so you know bold bets aws kindle
amazon prime our third-party seller
business
all of those things are examples of bold
bets that
that did work and they pay for a lot of
experiments
i've made billions of dollars of
failures
at amazon.com literally billions of
dollars of failures
and you know you might remember
pets.com or cosmo or
you know you give myself a root canal
with no anesthesia very easily
none of those things are fun but but
they also
they don't matter what really matters is
companies that don't
continue to experiment companies that
don't embrace
failure they eventually get in a
desperate position
where they the only thing they can do is
make a kind of hail mary bet
at the very end of their corporate
existence whereas companies that are
you know making bets all along even you
know
big bets but not bet the company bets i
don't i don't believe in bet the company
bets
that's when you're desperate that's
that's the last thing you can do
i think probably our most important
piece of intellectual property
is our brand name and i think people and
and i think this is very important for
anybody who's going to start a company
or
or or market an invention to understand
is that brands for companies are like
reputations for people
and reputations are hard earned and
easily lost
so the most important intellectual
property that a company can have
is for us it's that it's it's it's
amazon
it's that name but what it stands for
we've worked very hard
to earn trust you can't ask for trust
you just have to do it the hard way one
step at a time
you make a promise and then fulfill the
promise you say we'll deliver this to
you
you know tomorrow and then you actually
deliver it tomorrow
and if you do that over and over again
then ultimately you can instill your
company's
name with a reputation and that's i
think
you know sometimes people talk about
brands in this very amorphous way but
for me
i like to think of it as a person and
what is the reputation that that person
has and how have they earned that
reputation
after books we started selling music and
then we started selling um videos
and then i got smart and i um i emailed
a thousand
randomly selected customers and asked
them besides the things we saw today
what would you like to see us sell and
that
answer came back incredibly long tailed
the way they answered the question
was with whatever they were looking for
at that moment so like i remember one of
the answers was
i wish you sold windshield wiper blades
because i really need windshield wiper
blades
and i thought to myself we can sell
anything this way
and and then so then we launched
electronics and toys
and many other categories over time and
the
division became because you read the
original business plan it's just books
we all get um gifts
we get certain things in our life that
are
that we're very lucky about and one of
the most powerful one is who your early
role models are
you know you could they could it was
your grandfather it was in a big sense
my mom and dad but my grandfather too
and you know i had my mom had me when
she was
uh 17 years old and she was still in
high school
in albuquerque new mexico and this is in
1964. i can assure you that
being a pregnant teenager in high school
was not cool
in albuquerque new mexico at that time
and
uh so it's in in
so it was a very it was difficult for
her my grandfather went to bat for her
when they tried to kick her out of
school and you know he they're
they're incredible i had so the gift i
had is i had this incredible family
now that you have about 600 000
employees i calculated you're adding
about 250 people a day
um you've mentioned that you're trying
to fend off day two yeah
and you've said that day two is stasis
followed by irrelevance
followed by excruciatingly painful
decline followed by death
that is why it is always day one yeah
yeah how does that work
well so day one and this is a phrase
that we use at amazon all the
time i've been using it's in my first
annual shareholder letter from
20 years ago and we say it's always day
one
and it needs to be day one for the
reason that you just mentioned
um and how do you so the real question
for me is how do you go about
maintaining a day one culture you know
it's great to have
the um the scale of amazon we have
financial resources we have lots of
brilliant people
we can accomplish great things we have
global scopes we have operations all
over the world
but the downside of that is that you can
lose your nimbleness
you can lose your entrepreneurial spirit
you can lose your
that kind of heart the the the um that
small companies often have
and so if you could have the best of
both worlds
if you can have that entrepreneurial
spirit and heart
while at the same time having all the
advantages that come with scale and
scope
i think think of the things that you
could do and and so
how the question is how do you achieve
that um
the scale is good because it makes you
robust you know a a big boxer can take
a punch to the head the question is you
also want to dodge those punches
you'd like to be nimble you want to be
big and nimble
and i find there are a lot of things
that are protective of the day one
mentality i already spent some time on
one of them which is
customer obsession i think that's the
most important thing if you can
and it gets harder as you get bigger
when you're a little tiny company say
you're a 10 person startup company
every single person in the company is
focused on the customer
when you get to be a bigger company
you've got all the mil you've got middle
managers and you've got all these layers
and the those people aren't on the front
lines they're not interacting with
customers every day
they're insulated from customers and
they start to manage not the customer
happiness directly but they start to
manage through proxies like
metrics and processes and some of those
things can become bureaucratic so
it's very challenging but one of the
things that happens
is the decision-making velocity slows
down
and i think the reason one of the
reasons that that happens
is that people all the junior executives
inside the big company
start to model all decisions as if they
are heavyweight
irreversible highly consequential
decisions and so
even two-way doors you could make you
make a decision it's the wrong decision
you can just back up
back through the door and try again even
those reversible decisions start to be
made with heavyweight
processes and so you can teach people
that these pitfalls and and traps
and then teach them to avoid those traps
and that's what we're trying to do at
amazon so that we can maintain
our inventiveness and our heart and our
kind of small company's spirit even as
we have the scale and scope of a larger
company
i think it's the very rare idea that can
be done by a single individual
almost everything that is going to
change the world solve a problem
improve something these are usually big
efforts and they require
you know teams a team working together
to really get something important done
and that has been the story of
amazon.com at every step along the way
we've had a team here that is
is making this work i mean i don't know
even even at the smallest scale
you have to figure out how to get help
from your friends from your family
members
from people that you can hire in those
early days
i think without that it would never work
i believe in the power of
wandering all of my best decisions
in business and in life have been made
with heart intuition guts
you know not not
uh analysis um when you can
make a decision with analysis you should
do so but it turns out in life that your
most
important decisions are always made with
instinct intuition
taste heart i picked books because
there were more items in the book
category than any other category and so
you could build
universal selection there were three
million in 1994 when i was
pulling this idea together the the
three million different books active and
in print at any given time and the
largest physical bookstores only had
about 150 000 different titles
and so i could see how you could make a
bookstore online with universal
selection
every book ever printed even the out of
print ones was the original vision
for the company and so that's why books
and when did you know
that amazon is going to be some going to
be something way bigger than just a
bookstore
well i knew that the books strangely
because i was very prepared for this to
take a really long time i knew that the
books
um business was going to be successful
in the first 30 days
i was shocked at how many books we sold
we were
ill prepared um you know i had
we had all the we had only 10 people in
the company at that time
and most of them were software engineers
and so everybody including me and the
softwares were all like packing boxes
we didn't even have packing tables and
down we were on our hands and knees on a
concrete floor
packing the boxes and about you know one
or two in the morning i said to
one of my uh software engineering
colleagues
i said um you know paul
um we this is killing my knees
we need to get knee pads and paul looked
at me and he's like jeff
we need to get packing tables
and i was like oh my god that is such a
good idea
the next day i bought packing tables and
it doubled our productivity
and probably saved our backs and our
knees too my
greatest uh uh i would have such a good
feeling if i could be an 80 year old guy
and
laying there thinking about my life if i
could say look
there is now a bunch of entrepreneurs in
space
because i took my amazon lottery
winnings and built the heavy lifting
infrastructure
that does take billions of dollars in
capex
to lower the cost of access to space
that's how you get millions of people
living and working and by the way we
need that
for those of you who like to think about
the future
at all you can do a simple calculation
you know
we can argue about um you know what
limited resources on earth and so on and
so on but here's a calculation that you
cannot argue with
which is you take current baseline
energy usage on earth
compound it at just a few percent a year
for just a few hundred years
and you have to cover the entire surface
of the earth and solar cells
so you have to
we're going to have to decide do we want
a society
of pioneering invention expansion
growth or do we want a society of stasis
and personally i believe because the
earth is finite and if you want a
society of stasis
i think it's good first of all i don't
personally believe the stasis is even
compatible with freedom
so i think for me that's a big problem
second of all
it's going to be dull stasis is going to
be very dull you don't want to live in
the stasis world
and so of course we're going to continue
to get more efficient too we have been
for hundreds of years we've been getting
more productive more efficient
that's that trend is going to continue
but even so
we're going to want to use more energy
more energy per capita
and also i don't want to stabilize
population i would love for the
trillion humans in the solar system with
a trillion humans
we would have a thousand einsteins and a
thousand mozarts
it'd be an incredible symbol don't you
want that dynamism
it'd be so much more interesting my this
is for your great great great
grandchildren but what kind of world do
you want them to live in
i want them to live in that expansive
world that is
you know uh learning more about the
universe and moving out throughout the
solar system
if you want to be an inventor of any
kind inventing a new
you know a new service offering for
customers or a new product or anything
the being an inventor requires because
the world is so complicated
you have to be a domain expert i mean in
a way even if even if you're not at the
beginning
you have to learn learn learn learn
learn enough so that you become a domain
expert
but the danger is once you become a
domain expert you can be trapped by that
knowledge
and so inventors have this paradoxical
ability
to have that you know 10 000 hours of
practice and be a real domain
expert and have that beginner's mind
have that that look at it freshly even
though they know
so much about the domain and that's the
key
to inventing you have to have both and i
think
that is intentional i think all of us
have that inside of us
and we can all do it but you have to be
intentional about it you have to say
yeah i am going to become an expert and
i'm going to keep my beginner's mind
did i kind of anticipate what would
happen over the last 22 years
at amazon and the answer is god no so
you know amazon started as a very small
company
it was me and a few other people i was
driving
all the packages to the post office
myself in my 1987
chevy blazer and
when i raised money for amazon i had to
raise a million dollars
which i raised from 22 different
investors 50
000 each they got 20 of the company
for uh for the million dollars
and um it was
a 40 people told me no so i had to take
60 meetings
to get 20 yeses the first question was
always what's the internet
and i had to walk through that and this
was 1994
early 95. and so did i anticipate
you know fast forward to today and and
the current version of it
no it has been one foot in front of the
other
and i think that that is true for most
businesses
where you kind of proceed adaptively
it's step by step
you figure it out you have a success and
then you kind of double down on that
success and you figure out what
what else you can do what customers want
there are a lot of things that are a
waste of time you know when you think
about your life
i think i i often tell people that i
work with
if you can get because people people
have very high standards
for how they want their work life to be
and and i said look
if you can get your work life to be
where you
enjoy half of it that is a home
that is amazing because very few people
ever achieve
that because the truth is everything
comes with overhead
that's reality everything comes with
pieces that you don't like
you could be a supreme court justice and
there's still going to be pieces of your
job you don't like
you can be a university professor and
it's still going to be
you have to go to committee meetings and
you have to do you know
there are every job comes with pieces
you don't like
and we need to say that's just how
that's part of it
and and not resent those pieces or try
not to
but also try to minimize them i tell
senior executives
you should have the least stress you
know there's this weird
i think false idea
that ceos i'm a ceo there's this false
idea
that ceos are under the most stress
well i look at that i'm like why you're
in charge
why don't you delegate the stress it's
your choice
and uh so it's you have to figure out
how to
set up your life in such a way that you
can minimize the things
and i find people don't dislike hard
work
what people dislike and what is being
um out of control like they can't
control their life they can't control
their environment
this happens to me when i get over
scheduled
i hate being over scheduled i want some
time
to be able to think and free myself we
all have the same amount of time in the
world
nobody has more time than anybody else
and when you become a very successful
person
one of the things you start to get over
scheduled
you have this event you had to agree to
do this and maybe last night you were
like
why did i agree to do this i have to go
on stage tomorrow
i wish i would really with my family and
you know or i hope maybe not this case
let's say that you like this one but
in general that kind of thing happens
and so you have to guard your time and
and try to say a little bit flexible so
that's
for me it's not a waste of time but i
like
to have some freedom of movement
rather than having every minute of every
day
schedule when you buy over internet
amazon
do you ever get the wrong order is
anything ever wrong what do you do
do you call up and complain or you don't
have any problems no i i
i i'm a customer of amazon hopefully
like all of you in this is there one
person full time your services your
account
even this room is not an amazon customer
see me right afterwards and i'll um i'll
walk you through it it's um
i i yeah i get i have problems sometimes
um and i
and i treat them like the same way i
treat a problem that i would get from
customer my email address is famous
and i keep it and i read it it's jeff at
amazon.com i don't see every email that
i get anymore because i get too many
but i see a lot of them and i use my
curiosity
to pick out certain emails i'll get one
from a customer and
there's a defect you know we've done
something wrong that's the usually
people are writing us not always but
usually they're writing us because we've
screwed up their order somehow
and i am so i'm looking at this and for
some reason
something seems a little odd about that
one and so i'll ask the team to do a
case study
and and find real root cause or causes
it's usually causes
real root causes and then real root
fixes
so that when you fix it you're not
fixing it for that one customer you're
fixing it for every customer
and that process is a gigantic part of
what we do
so i would treat my if i have a failed
order or some bad customer experience i
would treat it just like that
when i started amazon it was 25 years
ago
i started amazon in 1994
when i went to seek investors the first
question i had to answer
is what is the internet none of my
investors had ever heard of the internet
and uh the
the the the the idea that i had in mind
was to build a bookstore i realized that
we could build a store
which would have every book ever printed
in any language in print or out of print
and we could do that online it would be
impossible
in a physical store and that was the
founding idea of amazon
and but did i expect what would happen
today no you know we started
i've been at amazon when it was one
person me
when it was 10 people when it was a
hundred people when it was a thousand
people
and today when it's you know more than
700
000 people and approaching 70 000 people
just here in india
so no i did not predict that and
actually i think if anybody had
predicted that they would have needed to
be immediately institutionalized in a
mental facility
because it's not a normal thing to have
happen my dream when i started amazon
was that one day we might be able to
afford a forklift
so it's been a very uh
fun journey for me and by the way i
still tap dance into work
i'm having so much fun amazon has 14
leadership principles and this is the
one that
often catches people belittled by
surprise
because one of our leadership principles
is that good leaders are right a lot
and it sounds kind of like well
great but is there some way that i can
practice
being right a lot and you're not going
to grab all the time
but i do think you with practice you can
be right more often and
i've observed people who are right a lot
and i notice a few things about them
the first is that people who are right a
lot they listen a lot
and people who are right a lot change
their mind a lot
and people who write a lot they seek to
disconfirm
their most profoundly held convictions
which is very unnatural for humans so
humans mostly as we go about life
we're very selective in the evidence
that we let
seep into us and we like to observe the
evidence that confirms
our pre-existing beliefs and people who
are right a lot
work very hard to do that unnatural
thing
of trying to disconfirm their beliefs i
uh
ask everybody to not think in two to
three year time frames but to think in
five to seven year time frames
to not think about when somebody says to
me congratulates amazon on
a good quarter which is a very common
thing to say you meet somebody they're
being nice
they looked at your financial results
for the quarter of a good quarter i say
thank you but what i'm thinking to
myself is
that quarter all that those quarterly
results were actually
pretty much fully baked about three
years ago and so like today
i'm working on you know uh a quarter
that is going to happen in 2020
not next quarter next quarter for all
practical purposes is done already and
it's probably been done for a couple of
years
and so if you start to think that way
it changes how you spend your time how
you plan
um where you put your energy um and and
your ability to look around corners gets
better so many things improve
if you can take a long term by the way
it's not natural for humans
so it's a it's a discipline that you
have to build the
um the kind of you know get rich slowly
schemes are not big sellers on uh
infomercials you know it's uh and so
that's something that you have to sort
of steal yourself for discipline and
teach
over time we all get to choose our life
stories and
it's the choices that define us not our
gifts everybody in this room has many
gifts
i have many gifts you can never be proud
of your gifts
because they're gifts they were given to
you you might be you know tall
and or you might be really good at math
or you might be extremely
beautiful or handsome or you know
they're
or they're many gifts and you can only
be proud really of your choices because
those are the things that you
are that you're that you are acting on
and one of the most
important choices that each of us has
and you know this just as well as i do
is you can choose a life
of ease and comfort or
you can choose a life of service and
adventure
and when you're 80 which one of those
things
you think you're going to be more proud
of you're going to be more proud of
having chosen a life of service and
adventure
what motivates me when times are rough
um
you know i find if i'm stressed about
something
it's usually because i'm not doing
anything about it
and so if i'm stressed about something
i'm trying to figure out why am i
stressed i'm listening to my body
as a signal that i'm that something is
awry and then i find that the stress
goes away
the second i take the first step of you
identify the source of the stress why am
i stressed about this
what's going on and then you know talk
to somebody about it
find you know find allies um you know i
would say that
uh if you can find um friends
uh who are interested in similar things
or want to help you solve a problem
problem solving is um is
inspiring for me all by itself i have as
long as i have
allies there's nothing more fun than
getting in a room
with a group of inventors
and saying look here's the problem let's
invent a solution to it
and as soon as you start doing that i
find that it turns from
something that might create stress into
something that
creates fun one of the reasons we have
been able to extend
into new business areas and first new
product categories going way back we
just sold books and then we started
selling music and
dvds and electronics and toys and so on
and then we've extended into electronic
reading with kindle
the reason customers have been receptive
in large part to our new initiatives
is because we have worked hard to earn
trust with them
earning trust with customers is
is a valuable business asset and if you
uh mistreat their data they will
no they will figure it out customers are
very smart you should never
underestimate customers
your stock at one point i think went to
100 but then it went down to six or
something like that
at the peak of the internet bubble our
stock peaked somewhere around 113
dollars
and then after the internet bubble uh
you know
busted open our stock went down to six
it went
from 113 to six in less than a year so
my annual shareholder that year starts
with a one word
sentence and that one word sentence is
the word ouch
so most of those internet companies of
the dot com era
are out of business yeah you survived
what was that that made you to survive
and virtually the rest of them are gone
um i it's very that whole period is very
interesting because the stock is not the
company
and the company is not the stock and so
as i watch the stock fall
from 113 to 6 i was also watching all of
our internal
business metrics number of customers
profit per unit
you know everything you can imagine
defects etc
every single thing about the business
was getting better and fast
and so as the stock price was going the
wrong way
everything inside the company was going
the right way and
um uh i you know so i wasn't we didn't
need to go back to capital markets we
didn't need more money
the only reason you know a financial
bust like the internet
bubble bursting is it makes it really
hard to raise money
but you know we already had the money we
needed so we just needed to continue to
progress
you know you don't choose your passions
your passions choose you and i would
always advise young people actually
anyone
you know to get in touch with what
you're really passionate about
and it's a gift to have a passion some
people are lucky they have more than one
passion they have two or three
and that gives you energy you can't
force a passion on yourself
it just doesn't work you can try but
it's unlikely to succeed
this work life harmony thing is what i
try to teach
young employees actually and senior
executives at amazon too but especially
the people coming i get we're asked
about work life balance all the time
and my view is that's a debilitating
phrase
because it it implies there's a strict
trade-off
and the reality is if i'm happy at home
i come into the office with tremendous
energy
and if i'm happy at work i come home
with tremendous energy
and so it actually is a circle it's not
a balance
and and i think that that is uh
is worth everybody paying attention to
you want to have
you never want to be that guy and we all
know we all have a co-worker
who is that person who as soon as they
come into the meeting they drain all the
energy out of the room
you can just feel the energy level go
that you don't want to be that guy
so you want to come into the office and
give everybody a kick in their step
the secret sauce of amazon where there
are several principles at amazon but the
number one thing that has made us
successful
by far is obsessive compulsive
focus on the customer as opposed to
obsession over the competitor and i talk
so often
to other ceos and
some other ceos and also founders and
entrepreneurs
and i can tell even though they're
talking about customers
they're really focusing on competitors
and it is a huge advantage to any
company
if you can stay focused on your customer
instead of your competitor
i have this great luxury i love my job i
tap dance into work even i get back i
just got back from an amazing vacation
in norway
i got to go dog sledding and go to a
wolf preserve
and all this really cool stuff but i
couldn't wait to get back to work
because it's so fun and the reason why
there is fun for me is
i get to work in the future so my job
i'm i'm
i have very um
limited kind of day-to-day operational
uh needs that you know i'm i've
constructed my job so that
i don't have to be pulled into the
present
i can stay two or three years in the
future everything i've ever done
has started small amazon started
with a couple of people and um
blue origin started with five people
and uh the budget of bloorigin was very
very small now the budget of blue
origins
approaches a billion dollars a year and
next year it'll be more than a billion
dollars
in amazon it literally was 10 people
today it's half a million people but you
you it's hard to remember for you guys
but for me it's like yesterday i was
driving the
packages to the post office myself and
um hoping one day we could afford a
forklift and so
so for me i've seen small things get big
and it's part of this day one mentality
i like treating things as if if they're
small you know
amazon even though it is a large company
i wanted to have the heart and spirit of
a small one
my approach to criticism and what i
teach and preach
inside amazon is when you're criticized
first look in a mirror and decide
are your critics right if they're right
change there are two kinds of critics
there are well-meaning critics
um who uh you know they
they're worried it's not going to work
but they do want it to work
and so it could be i could give you
example customer reviews would be one of
those um when we first did customer
reviews
20 years ago publishers or some book
publishers were not happy about it
because some of them were negative
and so it was very controversial
practice at that time but we thought it
was right and so we stuck to our guns
and
and and had a deep kill on that and
didn't didn't didn't change
um but uh there's a second kind
of critic which is the self-interested
critic and they come in all shapes and
sizes
you know they're um so they can be any
kind of institution
competitors of course and so
when you are doing something a new way
and if customers embrace the new way
what's going to happen is incumbents who
are practicing the older way
are not going to like you and they're
going to be self-interested critics and
so you do need as you're looking
yourself in the mirror to try and tease
those
two things apart we try to
create teams that are no larger than can
be fed with two pizzas
we call that the two pizza team rule um
no powerpoints
are used inside of amazon so every
meeting
we have when we hire a new executive
from the outside
this is the weirdest meeting culture
you will ever encounter and new
executives have a little bit of
you know culture shock in their first
amazon meeting because what we do
is somebody for the meeting has prepared
a six-page
memo a narratively structured memo that
is
got you know real sentences and topic
sentences
and verbs and nouns not just bullet
points
and it lays out and supposed to create
the context for what will then be a good
discussion
so and then we read those memos
silently in the meeting
so it's like a study hall and
we do that everybody sits around the
table and we read silently for
usually about half an hour however long
it takes us to read the
document and then we discuss it
and it's so much better than
the typical powerpoint presentation for
so many reasons
i definitely recommend the memo over the
powerpoint and
the reason we read them in the room by
the way is because just like
you know high school kids executives
will
bluff their way through the meeting as
if they've read the memo
because we're busy and so
uh you got to actually carve out the
time for the memo to get read and that's
what the first half hour of the meeting
is for and then everybody's
actually read the memo they're not just
pretending to have read
if you're going to do anything new or
innovative you have to be willing to be
misunderstood
and if you can't tolerate that then for
god's sake don't do anything new or
innovative
um every important thing we've done
has been misunderstood um
often by well-meaning sincere critics
sometimes of course by self-interested
uh
insincere critics i came across the fact
so this is 1994 nobody has heard of the
internet
very very few people and i came across
the fact that the web
world wide web was growing at something
like 2300 a year this is in 1994 and
anything growing that fast is
even if it's baseline usage today is
tiny
it's growing so fast it's going to be
big and so
i looked at that and i was like there's
got to be i should come up with a
business idea
and get you know on the internet and
then let the internet go around this and
we can keep working on it
and so i made a list of products that i
might saw online i started force ranking
them
and i picked books because books is
super unusual in one respect which is
that they're more book items in the book
category than there are items in the
other category they're three million
different
books active and in print around the
world at any given time
so my my the founding idea of amazon was
to build
universal selection of books the biggest
bookstores only had 150 000 titles
and so that's what i did and and i you
know i
hired a small team we built we built the
software i moved to seattle
and when you told your parents you're
going to quit the esha where you're
successful making presumably a fair
amount of money
yeah and you told your wife mackenzie
that you're going to move across the
country
what did they all say they were
immediately and reflexively supportive
right after they asked the question
what's the internet
we haven't had any existential crisis
knock on wood i
find i don't want to jinx anything um
but we've had a lot of uh kind of
dramatic events i remember um there
early on we only had 125
employees when barnes and noble who the
big
united states bookseller opened their
online website to compete against us
barnes noble.com we'd had about a
two-year
window we opened in 95 they opened in 97
and at that time all of the headlines
and the funniest were about how we were
about to be
destroyed by this much larger company we
had 125 employees
and 60 million dollars a year in annual
sales
60 million with an m and that
uh and barnes noble at the time had 30
000 employees and about 3 billion
dollars in sales
so they were giant we were tiny
and we had limited resources and the the
headlines were
very negative about amazon and the one
that's most minimal or
memorable was just amazon.toast
and um and so i called it all hands
meeting
which was not hard to do with just 125
people and we got in a room and
because it was so um scary for all of us
this idea that now we finally had a big
competitor
that literally everybody's parents were
calling and saying you know are you okay
it's usually the moms um calling and
asking their children are you gonna be
okay
so and i said look you know it it's okay
to be afraid
um but don't be afraid of our
competitors because they're never going
to send us any money
be afraid of our customers and if we
just stay focused on them in
in in in instead of obsessing over this
big competitor that we just got
that we'll be fine and i really do
believe that i think that if you stay
focused then the more
uh drama there is and everything else no
matter what the drama is whatever the
external distraction is
the the what your response to it should
be to
double down on the customer satisfying
them not just satisfying them delighting
them
you don't choose your passions your
passions choose you
and all of us are gifted with certain
passions
and the people who are lucky are the
ones who get to follow those things
and i always advise our young employees
and meet with interns and so on you can
have and my kids do
you can have a job or you can have a
career
or you can have a calling and if you can
somehow figure how to have a calling
you have hit the jackpot because that's
the big deal i'm actually a big fan of
anecdotes
in business not building a narrative
structure around them necessarily but
i still have an email address
that customers can write to i see most
of those emails
and i don't answer very many of them
anymore but
but i see them and i and i forward them
some of them the ones that catch my
curiosity
i forward them to the executives in
charge of that area
with a question mark and that question
mark is just a shorthand
for can you look into this why is this
happening what does it
what's going on and what i find is very
interesting is we have tons of metrics
we have you know weekly business reviews
with these
metric decks and we look at our we know
so many things about customers
and their uh their you know whether
we're delivering on time
uh what you know whether the uh
packages have too much air in them and
you know wasteful of packaging and so we
have so many metrics
that we monitor and the thing i have
noticed is that when the anecdotes
and the data disagree the anecdotes are
usually right
there's something wrong with the way
you're measuring it
and that's why it's so important to to
keep your
you need to run in something that you
were doing you know
shipping billions of packages a year for
sure you need good
data and metrics are you delivering on
time you deliver on time in every city
are you delivering on time to apartment
complexes are you delivering on time in
certain countries you do need the data
but then you need to check that data
with your intuition
and your instincts and you need to teach
that to the all the senior executives
and and junior executives the great
thing about
humans in general is we're always
improving things
and so entrepreneurs
and inventors and you know if they
follow their curiosity
and they follow their passions and they
figure something out and then they
figure how to make it better and they're
never satisfied
uh and and you need to harness that in
my view
you need to harness that energy uh
primarily
on your customers instead of on your
competitors and so where i see
i sometimes see companies and even young
small startup companies entrepreneurs go
awry is they start to pay more attention
to their competition than they do to
their customers
and i think that that um i think that in
big mature industries
that can be that might be a winning
approach in some cases kind of close
following let other people be the
pioneers and you know uh and
go down the blind alleys there's many
things that that a new inventive company
tries won't work
um and so those mistakes and errors and
failures do
cost real money um and and and so maybe
in a mature industry where growth rates
are slow and change is very slow but as
you see in the world
more and more there aren't very many
mature industries change is happening
everywhere
you know we see it in the automobile
industry with self-driving cars
and but you could go right down the line
of every industry and you would see it
you made it was there a moment you
thought
i might not make it the riskiest moment
for amazon
charlie was at the very very beginning
i needed to raise a million dollars at a
certain point
and i ended up giving away 20 of the
company for a million dollars a hell of
a deal for somebody
a lot of people did very well in that
deal
but they but they also took a risk so
they deserve to do very well on that
deal
but i um i had to take 60 meetings
to raise a million dollars and i raised
it from 22 people at approximately 50
thousand dollars a person
and it was nip and tuck whether i was
going to raise that money so the whole
thing could have ended before it even
started that was 1995
you know and the first question every
investor asked me was what's the
internet
failure and invention are inseparable
twins um
you know it's everybody wants to
be inventive you know if you go talk to
corporate america or
uh any any institution actually uh
government agencies and so on
innovation is something to be proud of
people like invention
but the problem is they don't like
failure
and you cannot have invention without
failure
if you
to know where if you already know it's
going to work it's not an experiment
and only through experimentation can you
get real invention
the most important inventions come from
trial and error
with lots of failure and the failure is
critical
and it's also embarrassing and so that's
why
people and when we're kids
we always are doing child error and
we're never embarrassed you know if you
watch a little toddler
and they will try for hours to put a
square peg in a round hole
and it never works but it doesn't keep
them from trying
and they try things like that and that's
how they learn and
and we all have that when we're little
and then as you get older somehow
it's not as cool as you get older to
fail and to fall down it looks clumsy
and so we get in our grooves we have a
set of expertise and skills it's kind of
a comfort zone
and you have to constantly push yourself
to say no
i don't care about failure in fact if
you know i say at amazon
we have to grow the size of our failures
as the size of our company grows we have
to make bigger and bigger failures
because otherwise none of our failures
will be needle movers
and so i would see it as a very bad sign
over the long run
if amazon wasn't making larger and
larger failures
and if you do that all along the way
that is going to protect you from ever
having to make
that big you know kind of hail mary bet
that you sometimes see
companies make right before they fail
and
go out of existence the most influential
people in my life were
my grandparents and i have a my
mother had me when she was 17 years old
she raised me
with my grandparents help and she was
still in high school when she had me
that was not
cool in albuquerque new mexico in 1964
but she did an incredible job but i was
lucky because i had not just her
but i had she re she married my father
when i was about four years old he has
been a huge influence in my life
but my grandmother and grandfather were
like second set of parents from me
and you learn different things from them
because they're at a different stage of
life and they know different things
they're calm about certain things
it was a huge gift to me
my grandfather was a had a ranch in
texas
and i spent all my summers there from
like age 4 to 16
and he was the most self-reliant person
he did all of his own veterinary work
all the things i mean and to
observe him solve problems and figure
out how to do things with no tools and
no
resources and you know very small
amounts of money
it was a huge education from an early
age
so we're very like one of the things
that you i know people
who have they don't have
great family situations and
sometimes they break that cycle and they
are the ones who
pull out of it those people are the ones
i reserve my
highest admiration for as the owner of
the post i know that
at times the post is going to write
stories they're going to uh
make very powerful people very unhappy
are you upset if they are writing
critical stories about amazon which they
do no
i'm not upset at all when i first
brought the position
and i'd never i would be humiliated to
interfere i would be so embarrassed i
would
i would turn bright red and it has
nothing to do
with um i don't even get so far i just
don't want to
for me it would feel icky it would feel
gross it would feel it would be one of
those things when i'm 80 years old
i would be so unhappy with myself if i
interfered
why would i i want that paper to be
independent
we would be very naive to believe that
we're not going to be criticized i mean
that's just part of the terrain you have
to accept that one
that i tell people is if you're going to
be if you're going to do anything new or
innovative you have to be willing to be
misunderstood
if you cannot if you can't afford to be
misunderstood then for goodness sake
don't do anything new or innovative
by the way getting it wrong isn't that
bad that's the other thing
when when when we make mistakes and
we've made doozies like the fire phone
and many other things that just didn't
work out i can i could
we don't have enough time for me to list
all of our failed experiments
but the big winners pay for thousands of
failed experiments so you try something
like prime
and it was very expensive at the
beginning it cost us a lot of money
because what happens when you offer a
free
all you can eat buffet who shows up to
the buffet first
the heavy eaters it's scary
it's like oh my god did i really say as
many prawns as you can eat
and um and so that is what happened but
sure but surely we could see the trend
lines we could see that you know
the dif all kinds of customers were
coming and they appreciated that service
my grandparents would take me every
summer
eve starting at age four every summer
kind of to give her a break really um
for the whole summer
so i'd be with my grandparents and on
their ranch in catulla texas which is
halfway between san antonio and laredo
we lived in houston and uh so we would
make the five-hour drive out to catoula
they'd drop me off
spend a couple of days there then they'd
go back to houston i'd spend the summer
and i went every day to the ranch with
my grandfather
to help now a four-year-old boy
on a ranch in south texas is not a lot
of help
um but i didn't know that i thought i
was helping and
and then as i by the time i was 16 i
actually was helping
so i have you know i i can
i can suture up a prolapsed cow
i can fix windmills my grandfather was
so resourceful
and that he made his own veterinary
needles
he would take a little piece of wire and
pound it flat with a was like a
oxyacetylene torch and then drilled a
little hole through it
and then we would do we did all of our
own veterinary work some of the cattle
even survived
and uh so we had but we had
great fun out there you know um we
built barns and welded things and he
bought a
d6 uh caterpillar bulldozer
used it was like 1955 model year
for five thousand dollars was completely
broken the gears were stripped
and then we spent you know a whole
summer repairing that
the first thing we had to do to repair
it was build a crane to take the gears
out of the transmission
and so you know what i learned from
watching him was just how resourceful he
was
one of the precursors one of the
foundational things
to being able to take risk is to have
had
some kind of support from somebody you
have to have some mentors
you have to have somebody who loves you
these are the kind of things that build
up and allow you
to kind of you know jump off into
uncharted terrain and do something new
because you know you have
a support system of one kind or another
and
uh and i certainly did so for me i just
want to point out that i've
i i feel very strongly that um
there's a lot i've won a lot of
lotteries uh amazon is one of the
lotteries that i've won
but i had a big lottery with my parents
my dad is a cuban immigrant
he came here when he was 16 years old
didn't speak any english
uh my he's a great guy
and my mother had her
had me when she was 17 years old so she
was a pregnant
16 year old in albuquerque new mexico in
high school which was not cool
and she made it work and her her parents
my grandparents helped her with that
whole thing and made
made that all work and if you don't get
that kind of
support somehow it doesn't have to be
your parents sometimes people get lucky
it's a grandparent or it's a friend or a
family friend or a teacher
it can be somebody but you need that
somebody has to step into your life
and that's a lottery that i suspect a
lot of people in this room have
also won just like me i like to putter
in the morning i get up early i go to
bed early
i get up early i like to putter in the
mornings i like to read the newspaper i
like to have coffee i like to have
breakfast with my kids before they go to
school so i have
my kind of puttering time is very
important to me
and so that's why i set my first meeting
for 10 o'clock
i like to do my high iq meetings before
lunch like anything that's going to be
really
mentally challenging that's a 10 o'clock
meeting and because by 5 p.m
i'm like i can't think about that today
let's try this again tomorrow at 10 a.m
and um and so then on sleep
i get eight hours of sleep i prioritize
it unless i'm traveling in different
time zones sometimes it's impossible but
i am very um focused on it and and
and for me i need adults to sleep i
think better i have more
energy my mood is better all these
things i'm taking my amazon
lottery winnings and i'm converting them
into reusable rocket vehicles
so that we can lower the cost
of access to space because right now the
price of admission to do
interesting things in space is just too
high if i look at what
amazon was able to do 20 years ago
we didn't have to build a transportation
network it already existed that heavy
lifting was in place
we didn't have to build a payment system
that heavy lifting had already been done
it was the credit card system
we didn't have to build and put a
computer at every desk that had already
been done too mostly for playing games
by the way and so on so all the pieces
of heavy lifting
were already in place 20 years ago and
that's why
as a with a million dollars i could
start this company
today you know and then there are even
better examples on the internet over the
last 20 years you know
facebook started in a dorm room i
guarantee you two kids cannot build a
giant space company in their dorm room
it's impossible but i want to create the
heavy lifting
infrastructure kind of do the hard part
so that
a future the future generation two kids
in a dorm room will be able to create a
giant space company
i always tell people sometimes i get you
know we'll have a good
quarterly conference call or something
and and wall street will like
our quarterly results and i'll get
people will
stop me and say congratulations on your
quarter and i say thank you but what i'm
really thinking is
that quarter was baked three years ago i
right now i'm working
on a quarter that's going to reveal
itself in 2021 sometime
and that's what you need to be doing you
need to be out sort of you know
two or three years in advance and if you
are and then why do i need to make 100
decisions today
if i make like three good decisions a
day that's enough
take pride your choices aren't your
gifts this is something that um
i would i think is super important for
young people to understand and for
parents to preach to young people it's
really easy for
a talented young person to take pride in
their gifts they can say you know
i'm really athletic or i'm really smart
or i'm really good at math
and that's fine you should celebrate
your gifts you should be happy
but you can't be proud of them because
they're gifts after all
they were given to you what you can be
proud of is your choices
how did you decide to use your gifts did
you
study hard did you work hard did you
practice
the people who really excel combine gift
gifts and hard work and the hard work
part is a choice
you get to decide that and that is
something
when you're looking back on your life
you'll be very proud of
i was living and working in new york
city in 1994
and came across the fact that the world
wide web was growing very quickly it was
tiny
but it was growing very fast most people
had not heard of it
and i came up with this idea the idea
initially was very simple it was to sell
books
online and i went to my boss who i liked
a lot his name was david
and i said i have this idea to start
this company to sell books on the
internet
and he took me on a long walk in central
park in new york
and listened to this idea in great
detail
and he said it actually sounds like a
really good idea to me
but i think it would be a better idea
for somebody
who didn't already have a good job and
i thought about that that made a certain
amount of sense to me
and he said why don't you think about it
for two days before you make a final
decision
and so i went away and i thought about
this and i was trying to figure out how
to make this
decision because in the moment personal
life decisions those choices can be very
challenging
and i finally figured out for me the
right way to think about it which was
i wanted not to have regrets i pictured
myself
you know 80 years old and thinking back
on my life in a quiet moment of
reflection
would i regret leaving this
company in the middle of the year and
walking away from my
annual bonus and all those things that
in the moment could be very confusing
and i thought you know when i'm 80 i'm
not going to think about that i'm not
even going to remember it
but what i will do i know for a fact
i have this idea and if i don't try
i'm going to regret having never tried
and i know also
if i try and fail i'll never regret
having tried and failed and as soon as i
thought about it that way
i knew i had to give it a try we're very
interested in physical stores
and we haven't i've been asked for years
we ever opened physical stores literally
20 years i've been asked that question
and i always say
yes but only when we have a
differentiated
differentiated offering something that's
not me too
because that space physical storage is
so well served if we
offer a me to product offering it's not
going to work
we're and it's also just we're not very
good at that most of the whenever we've
tried
dabbling in something that's a me too
service we tend to get
beaten it doesn't work we're our culture
is much better at pioneering and
inventing and
so we have to have something that's
different and that's what amazon go is
it's completely different the amazon
bookstore completely different
and we have ideas about how to merge
prime and whole foods to make that those
are still rolling out you haven't seen
them yet
but to make to use amazon prime to make
whole foods
a very differentiated experience and so
what we're going to be able to do is
take some of our resources some of our
technical
technological know-how and and expand
the whole foods mission
they have a great mission which is to
bring nourishing food to everybody
organic nourishing food to everybody and
but you know we have a lot to bring to
that table in terms of resources but
also in terms of
operational excellence and in terms of
technology know-how
be stubborn on vision and flexible on
details
the um you really can't accomplish
anything
important if you're not stubborn on
vision because things that are important
take a long time
you take teams you can't do it by
yourself and so you really need to
you need to have a crisp idea of the
vision you need to stay incredibly
relentless on that vision
but you need to be flexible on the
details because
you've got to be experimental to
accomplish anything important
and that means you're going to be wrong
a lot and so you're going to try
something
on your way to that vision and that's
going to be the wrong thing the wrong
decision you're going to have to back up
take a little course correction and try
again
and so you cannot be stubborn on the
details
you have to be flexible on the details a
young person
starting their career
i think there are probably a lot of
things some of them are very well known
and people have heard them many times
they're still true
one of those is you should always focus
on a young person should
find something that they're passionate
about to do
and that's not going to surprise anyone
it's it's a clear thing to do it's very
hard if you don't love your work
you're never going to be great at it
i think the other thing i would suggest
to any young person even before they
start their career
is to really think about their choices
because i find young people and i
i when i was young i had i made this
mistake too
you can get very fixed on your
gifts so everybody has gifts you know
you you have gifts and you have things
that you didn't get gifted maybe you're
extremely beautiful maybe you're
extremely good at mathematics maybe you
there are a lot of things that you can
be given but those things can confuse
you
because they're not the things that
construct your life it's your choices
that construct your life
not your gifts you can celebrate your
gifts be proud of them be happy of them
actually don't be proud of them be be
celebratory of them because you can't be
proud because they're gifts they were
given to you you didn't earn them
you can only be proud of the things you
earn and so
as i got older i started to realize i
wasn't proud of my
gifts i was always good at school school
was always easy for me
and i was always proud that i was a
great student i got a's in all my
classes
i was good at math all of that and i
thought
i thought that's who i was but it's not
true
those are the things that are gifts what
was hard for me is deciding to work hard
deciding to use my gifts in certain ways
to challenge myself to do things that i
didn't think i could do to put myself in
uncomfortable situations
we all get i would say to a young person
you can choose a life
of ease and comfort or you can choose
a life of service and adventure which
one of those when you're 90 years old
are you going to be more proud of look
um we would all love all of our numbers
to be smooth
lines up and to the right and uh that
would be terrific but
that's not how it works you know um you
know the
those numbers are our output
measures and you i mean i guess you
could try to manage your quarterly
earnings
very precisely but i think personally
that would be a mistake you know most of
the work that we put into um any
particular
quarter happened years ago so it's not
you know there's there aren't that many
knobs you can turn during a quarter i
mean you can but they're very they're
like eating your seed corn
if you turn those knobs you don't want
to do that and so
uh it's it's uh uh i
you know people uh i think if you focus
on
the controllable inputs to your business
instead of the outputs
in the long term you get better results
amazon one of the things we try to do
is have multiple paths to yes
and so here's here's a little thought
experiment for you
if you are a junior
executive at amazon and that if
amazon did this in the typical kind of
corporate hierarchy way
you had an idea you need to get your
boss
to green light that idea and then your
boss's boss
needs to green light that idea and then
your boss's boss's boss
needs to greenlight that idea they're
probably five levels
or more before that idea gets the
go-ahead
assume instead that you're an
entrepreneur with a startup company idea
and you need venture capital you go to
sandhill road
and you go to the first venture
capitalist and they tell you no
and you go to the second one and they
tell you no
you're maybe your 20th one tells you yes
you've got 19 no's and one yes
and you're still good to go so that
that venture capital model is there's
multiple paths to yes
there were 20 people who could give you
a yes and it didn't matter how many gave
you a no
so if you want innovative thinking you
have to think about
how can we get you want a large number
of high judgment people
empowered to green light things you want
multiple paths
to yes you want a system where as a
junior
air force officer with a good idea
the first five people tell me no and
somehow i can still go pursue that idea
so you gotta figure out that's an
organizational um
uh challenge that big organizations have
to figure out a way to do
and by the way i get you know
this happens all the time i'll say i
don't think that's a good idea but
somebody else will greenlight it and i'm
fine with that because usually the cost
of the experiments is pretty small
things only get expensive when they work
right once something works you're like
whoa we need to double down on that now
and then the spending can get heavy and
then those become big consequential
decisions and that's where the hierarchy
and the
using the judgment of the most senior
people to me this really helps
sure well two pizza teams is something
that we've been preaching at amazon
follows from the very beginning and it's
a simple idea which is
no team should be so large that it
cannot be fed with just two pizzas
and so obviously to do great things you
need big teams
but you need to subdivide them and the
reason that it's so helpful is because
there's a natural we humans grew up
around campfires and telling each other
stories
and you're sitting at tables tonight
that have about 10 people at each table
10 people maybe 12 people is the perfect
size
to have a natural uh human coordination
without a lot of structure and if you
want to have a big group of 100 people
or 500 people
uh organized you have to have a lot of
structure to make that work
and so if you can arrange to do big
things
with a multitude of small teams and that
takes a lot of effort to organize that
way
but if you can figure that out the
communication on those small teams will
be very natural and easy
you know warren buffett has this great
quote he says you can hold a
rock concert and that's okay and you can
hold a ballet
and that's okay just don't hold a rock
concert and advertise it as a ballet
investors come in all shapes and sizes
they have
different investment horizons different
approaches different
beliefs about what the right kind of
portfolio
looks like and so it's not one you know
people
use wall street as a shorthand but there
isn't one type of investor
they come in all shapes and sizes and
you have to be super clear
about what kind of company you're trying
to build what your approach is we laid
that out in our 1997 annual shareholder
letter
we said we were going to take big bets
we said they were going to fail
we said some of them hopefully we're
going to work we said we were going to
invest
for the long term that we were going to
try to take advantage of
market opportunities as they arose and
there's a certain kind of investor
who is aligned with that approach and so
again
you can hold the ballet or the rock
concert and both can work
um just be clear about which one you are
and then people can self-select
now i've got a very special bonus clip
that i think you're going to enjoy
but before that it's time for the
question of the day
i want to know what was your single
biggest takeaway from this video
and your plan of action for the next
week when you get motivated
inspired you have a 35 chance of
following through but when you get
motivated inspired and you create a plan
of action
you have a over 90 chance of following
through and when you share with other
people
it jumps to 95 chance your likelihood of
following through and so i want that to
be you
from this video we don't just watch
videos here believe nation we do
something we take action
so i want to know your single biggest
takeaway from this video
and your plan of action for the next
week leave it down in the comments below
because i want to celebrate you i think
this is a golden age of television so
when you look at
you know tv series today the really good
tv
series are in terms of quality they're
as good as the very best
movies have ever been and you now you're
getting the best storytellers
to come to television you're getting the
best actors
to now come do television which is one
of the great storytellers that's right
here thank you for the help
and this is this is a big deal
when when you can get the very best
people because this is
you this is one of those businesses
where
the viewer the the the
is always looking for something a little
fresh
and so you can never find a formula
because as soon as you find a formula
it's not fresh anymore
they're always looking for something a
little new so it really takes human
ingenuity it takes people
the storytellers have to be in touch
with the zeitgeist
and what i want amazon studios to be all
over the world
i want us to be known as the most talent
friendly studio in the world and the
reason you need to do that
thank you
[Music]
is because at the end of the day it is
the talent
that makes those stories storytelling is
the oldest thing that humans do
we've been doing it for thousands and
thousands of years
long before there was written language
before there was any medium to convey it
people sat around
and they told each other stories and
it's how we teach each other things
and we learn from stories we learn from
fiction
we learn from fiction because we get to
live an alternate life
in that moment you watch this and you're
learning it so
it can be fun it can be action it can be
funny it can be comedy
but the very best things take those
elements
and teach a little something there's
something in there that you walk away
with
and you're inspired by it and it doesn't
matter if it's drama
comedy anything you're gonna walk away
with something
and there needs to be lightness you know
you can't watch something that's just
all heavy and you're like oh my god
you know i want to kill myself now there
also has to be that gesture there has to
be somebody who brings you out
and lets you breathe a little bit so
these and this is
so hard to do that's why there is so
much
bad so many bad movies and so many bad
tv shows because it's
inc it's it is one of the hardest things
that humans do
is tell riveting engaging
inspiring stories but when you get it
right it's a lever that can change the
world
if you want some amazing motivation from
elon musk check out the video right
there next to me i think you'll enjoy it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there i think failure is bad
um i don't think it's good um but if
if something's important enough then you
you do it even though the risk of
failure is high
and and so i think